a series of powerful successive
earthquakes struck the Turkish Syrian
border on February 6th the first and
most powerful was a 7.8 magnitude Quake
this region certainly hasn't seen an
earthquake this size in centuries
destruction followed as aftershocks hit
the region then a second 7.5 magnitude
Quake hit in the afternoon followed by
its own series of aftershocks in their
wake a humanitarian and economic crisis
thousands of people are reported dead
and even more are still missing
it's not the first time this region has
suffered a violent quake and it won't be
the last to understand why you have to
look under the surface where three
tectonic plates converge together these
plates cause a unique and potentially
devastating type of earthquake the first
Quake was located here 11 miles under
the town of gaziantep turkey 11 miles
may sound deep but that's actually
shallow for a major Quake the town is
especially vulnerable because it sits
near the meeting of two tectonic plates
tectonic plates are massive slabs of
rock on the Earth's crust from 10 miles
to 160 miles thick that are always
slowly moving
you can take the Earth and divide it up
into several Lodge plates that are all
moving around each other and most
earthquakes occur at the boundaries
between those those plates this one is
called the Anatolia
plate it's actually a micro plate due to
its tiny size and it's constantly Under
Pressure that's because it's being
pressed upward against the Eurasia plate
by the Arabia plate that pressure is
squeezing the Anatolia plate Westward
where it faces even more friction from
the Africa plate which is also moving
upward the Anatolian microplate is quite
an advised between the Arabian plate
moving to the north against the Eurasian
plate and this small plate is being
pushed aside as a result of that motion
that means the boundary degrees between
the Anatolia plate and the Africa and
Arabia plates are trying to slide
against each other as the Anatolia moves
to the west and the Africa and Arabia
move to the east these borders are
called strike slip faults and when the
friction builds up between the plates as
they're push in different directions
until it's too much they slip that's a
strike slip earthquake The Strain will
build up and finally it will rupture and
release all that accumulated strain in a
large earthquake that's what happened
resulting in that 7.8 magnitude Quake
USGS estimates that the strike slip
occurred along about 100 miles of the
fault about 20 miles shorter than most
strike slip earthquakes these are
significant earthquakes for this fault
system and so that is probably an
accumulation of three to five hundred
years worth of strain that's built up
since the last earthquake experts say
the energy released in that slip is
comparable to that released during the
explosive 1980 Mount St Helens volcanic
eruption the same thing happened nine
hours later in Econo Zoo resulting in a
7.5 magnitude Quake this one was just
six miles down more than 285 aftershocks
have followed both Quakes USGS has
called the area tectonically active and
unstable this region is certainly one of
the more complicated parts of the world
because there are four different plates
into interacting so it becomes a region
with very complex tectonics
complex tectonics are responsible for a
long history of devastating Quakes like
this Quake from 1966 that killed over 2
000 people towns and villages in 19
provinces are almost totally destroyed
the 600 Mile North Anatolian fault
produced seven large strike slip
earthquakes from 1939 to 1999 and three
earthquakes of magnitude 6 or larger
have occurred within 155 miles of
Monday's earthquakes since 1970 but
there hasn't been a large earthquake
since 1999. because this region hasn't
seen a large earthquake for a while it
was was overdue that 1999 Quake was a
7.4 magnitude and caused an estimated 17
000 deaths
for now USGS estimates there could be
billions in economic losses the biggest
thing is the destruction and loss of
life and and it's going to take them
years for recovery but will there be
more disruption if the two Quakes spark
a third experts aren't sure it may put
extra strain on some of the nearby
faults or it may relieve some of the
strain on the nearby faults so it'll
take some time to figure out whether
further earthquakes are more likely or
less likely in in this region but due to
the three plate convergence it's not a
question of if there will be another
earthquake it's a question of when